Mmh.
We can't hear you, but we can't see you. No, we can only see you too.
Hey, Tony. We can hear you, Tony.
OK, good. OK, good. OK.
Okay, great. Thank you. Okay.
Yeah.
Yep.
Mm.
Hello, how are you doing?
I think that I'm there.
Okay.
No.
It.
S.
Ashish, if you think something.
You know, Sophia, I was, I was having a normal chat with Sally and she was using this word por favor quite often.
Mhm.
Yeah.
And then I realized it means please in Spanish.
Yes, so funny story. I was working and I was in a cold with Sally and my kid was there and he was annoying me, my kid. So I just, I thought that I closed the mic and I was saying in Spanish to my kid, stop bothering me.
Kip.
Please stop it. But Sally has been hearing it and they were like, what language do you speak? And I was like, Spanish.
He heard it.
Okay, yeah, that was fun. All right, well, thank you so much, Sophia, for accommodating time to have this call. As you know, that we are out this Friday and next Friday too, so we will just...
Hmm.
Mhm.
having this call today. So yeah, you mentioning that you had a few things to discuss about Sally. So over to you.
Yes, so I thought that we were...
in a better position with Sally. But these two days that Sally was off, I was covering for her. I was doing the payment applications. And last week, I did follow ups to the clients. When they came back, they were asking for some payments that they did.
So that is what bring to my attention what the things that I'm going to tell you now. So we have go through with Sally that she has to apply the payment as per the remittance. She is allowed to apply to any older invoice when we don't have the remittance and when it matches the information.
But if we have the remittance, she has to follow it. So what I found out is that the remittance says something and she applied to whatever other invoice that we have in the system. That is one thing. Another one is that the client was applying credits.
to the payments and she just select another credits for that payment. And that makes a discrepancy because those credits were already applied to another two invoices. So by mistake, the client was duplicating the credits, but she just applied it without
having these in thinking about that it was duplicate. So this is the two things with the payments. Another thing that I found out is that she is saying that it's done, the payment application, but it's not really done. So let me share.
my screen so I can show you what I'm saying. Just give me a second, let me find out.
Let me know when you can see my screen.
Begin.
Okay, so this is my chat with Sally.
On Monday, when I was working, I sent these on June 8th. I sent, please post these in QuickBooks. This is a payment. This is a Reza payment. And she said that she did. And when I was checking, the payment was not applied. It was not posted to the client.
This one, what we do in our process is when we finish with the bank transactions, we fill with the color. This is her color. It's a kind of pink or purple, something like that. And it's selected that it's posted and everything is done here. It was not done.
Okay.
So, basically, she highlighted, she highlighted this whole payment application, but it was not posted in QuickBooks.
The other one.
Exactly.
Yes, so just, yes, just to clarify, so it looks like it's done, but when Sophia checked in QuickBooks and under the customer, it was it was not completed.
Uh-huh.
Is Nathan.
This one is about the remittance that I mentioned. The payment was incorrectly applied. The remittance was not followed. Incorrect credit memos were applied to this payment. So this one creates a lot of issue with this client because they have
I.
another credit to be applied and it just make a discrepancy. I'm still talking with them to fix this, but this is the kind of thing that I'm now constantly finding with Sally. And the other one is billing questions. So this is payment application, this is billing questions.
She sent me this screenshot. Can you see the screenshot?
Yeah, if you could please click on it, that would, yeah.
Yeah.
For sure. This is what the client is saying. So she sent me the screenshot and she sent me the ticket number. By this, what you are reading here, what I read is that the client is asking if the invoice that they are sending is going to be charged to the invoice.
Okay.
to the credit card, sorry. And I asked her, what happened with this? And she's telling me, they want to know whether the invoice will be billed to the account. What is that even mean?
We don't bill to it. We, Sally and I, we don't bill to the client. We apply payment to the invoice and we respond to billing questions. These kind of questions, I have talked to her many times now. This is one of the current questions that we have with the client. We have this a lot of times.
So I think that she should be...
She should have the knowledge enough to answer these kind of things.
So I have to explain her that they are asking if we are going to charge the credit card on file.
So these kind of questions, billing questions,
She should know. At this moment, she should know. She's working with me like six months now, I think.
And she's receiving six months, right? And we receive these type of questions every month.
She'll be completing six months, so yeah, so.
So I just have one clarity question here, Sophia. This billing question which Sally asked. Yes, so, and the type of question that she's been asking, are they new? Because, you know,
Sure.
This one?
With accounting, we have different scenarios with different customers, different situations. So just wanted to know if there is a repetition of the question that she had asked in the past or is it something unique?
Mm.
This, this not a new scenario, this is not new.
Okay.
And so yeah, we accept. So this was a miss and the person we connected in our previous connect, Gautam, so he's the head of accounting internal to ITBD. So he is working with her to ensure that.
The such issues do not repeat. Hey, Manan, hey, Manan, how are you?
Hello, good, thank you.
Mm.
Doing good. Thank you. The QuickBook payment issue, Sophia, that you showed us, even I was checking this with Sally, I believe there was some delay in syncing because part of the work was done in ConnectWise and then it had to be manually synced.
to QuickBooks.
That, that is another one.
Yeah.
That is another one, so let me, let me take my...
Dino.
So, Sophia, Tammy, Manan, thank you for sharing. And I know you're going to bring it up. That's fine. I'm hearing this. Hi, everyone. Good to see you all again. I'm hearing this, and I know you started saying, hey, we saw some things going on the right path, and now you're pulled into a scenario and you're seeing
No.
some gaps and some stuff. Our objective here is always to fix and close those gaps, help fix and close those gaps where we can. One thing, and I want you the opportunity to share the nuance of that specific scenario, but the one thing that I'll ask,
You know, as Ashish just said, we have one of our heads of finance, our head of finance, engaged to help work with Sally, right? Because we want to make sure that she is improving to the point where her value
Yeah.
is worth it, right? Like that, that's the goal of these engagements. It's what we do with any other team member that we have at MSP Corp. And so we're engaging somebody with that exact expertise. What I would request from you all is, is.
Mhm.
and I'll talk to the team to Ash to Keith, is let's have one of two things. Either if you have SOPs drafted, like standard operating procedures for various things drafted that Sally has been shared and should be operating off of.
Ohh.
I.
then if you could share those with us as a group, what we can do is we can go help facilitate further and deeper discussion around it with her. And then #2, if you don't, or if you think it would be beneficial to supplementally do this, I know Gautam had joined another call, it might be worth us
doing a few of those to align on the things that you see most frequently, right? Either, hey, this is a process that always happens and we don't see any pain points with Sally with it yet, but we want to make sure it's locked and loaded just as a precaution because that happens frequently enough where it would be a huge pain point if it did fall through.
or these are the repeated kind of issues that were performance gaps that we're noticing directly with Sally, and here's the right path so that we can help document if it doesn't exist on your side already. And that way we can give her a nice clean runbook.
I.
and Gautam can help with Ashish or Keith or myself, whoever it is on this side, who's in a position to help continue to push her in that right direction, we have a clear indication of like, hey, here's the delta, here's where you need to be. This is
this is how to get there because we have now very clear instruction documented for her so that she's not
Yeah.
trying to remember if she, if that's what she's doing now, right? And if it is in the stuff documented, then we want to be able to point her to, hey, why aren't you going back to this document that Sophia or Tammy or whoever already gave you? So I guess that starts with the first question. Are these,
processes all, when she was trained on them, was she trained from a process documentation? Was she trained from a shadowing perspective? What was the onboarding like?
Shadowin.
Okay, and it's fine that these process, a lot of business lines don't require, you know, standard operating procedures to be documented or don't get to that point because it's usually a small tight-knit group and tribal knowledge goes a long way. And it genuinely does. When we're trying to fold in a new team member, though,
There's a lot of value, I think, in documenting some of those. Do you guys have anything documented already that's been shared or hasn't been shared?
We have something, but as we used to do before, because now it's honestly it's too simple to have a document because she just have to read the remittance, follow the instructions, apply the payment.
Oh, okay.
Mm.
Okay, okay, but we're seeing different types of, we're seeing failures across different types of tasks right now, right?
She has two tasks. Payment application, billing questions.
Okay.
So payment application is where she is saying that is done, but is not really done, is not posted in QuickBooks. And she's not following the instructions that the client is giving us.
Mhm.
So 2 things that is really, sorry, but it's easy to follow if you just read the information and apply the payment, right?
Okay.
Thanks.
You don't.
Yeah, you don't have to apologize. Totally, totally hurt. And, and if it, if it is in fact that simple of tasks, then it's then it's worth us.
Mm.
taking a look at that in a little bit deeper lens. And yeah, let me talk to, and I know, thank you, by the way, for entertaining my line of question. I want to make sure that I understand where the pain point is so I can be most effective in helping. So I appreciate you guys sharing. I had heard some.
from the group, but it's always beneficial to hear from you guys too. Yeah. No, please.
Well, sorry to interrupt. What I can see is that maybe she is lacking of detail orientation because she is doing only that. She's not receiving phone calls, she's not receiving emails, she's not receiving tickets while she's doing the payment application.
Okay.
In these two days that I was doing that for her, for me, it took around one hour to finish. And it's the same amount of transactions that she had yesterday, sorry, today, yes, yesterday and today. So I should expect the...
same amount of time to doing that. And I'm taking phone calls, I'm receiving emails, I'm receiving tickets and things like that, but I can do it in one hour. And she's taking two hours, two hours and a half, and I have these kind of issues. So that is what really upsets me because she's supposed to be focusing this task.
with no distractions and it should be perfect.
Yeah.
Understood. No, that's helpful to know. Ashish, Keith, Sarbjeet. Let's huddle after this and talk to Katarmal as well. I want to see what, I want us as a group to talk about both what we're hearing today, what we had heard in the past, and what Gautam has already
Sure.
done in the past. I want to see if this is a question of skill, will, or what, right? I just want to make sure, because, you know, and I know that we've spent some time, you pointed out, it's been about six months. I'm a firm believer that
Yeah.
Just because you walk in the wrong door doesn't mean you're stuck in that room, right? I'd much rather us find the person that's going to make your life so much easier that you're looking for other things for them to do than if that's the right recommendation.
Oh.
I don't have a just full enough context yet to make that determination, but that's kind of the eyes we'll look at this with is figure out, hey, what's our real recommendation now, given the recurrence of some of these pain points? Because we do want to make sure, like I said, we want to make sure that
Whoever you're working with on our side, just like we're getting from a number of other business lines, that they're coming back and saying, "Yeah, this person's making our life easier." Good, that's what they're supposed to be doing, so we'll talk internally and circle back with.
Yeah.
Yes.
some an action plan, like a very clear action plan, and recommendation.
Perfect.
Yes, because correct me if I'm wrong, Manan, but the idea was that Sally took over other things too, because now she's doing really simple things and I'm still guiding her.
Yes.
No, no, she's, yeah. So technically for me, yes, she, the primary is making sure that all the payment are applied every day, okay, that we answer everything that is basic question from the client, sending a statement, sending an invoice.
all of things she needs to do. There's a task, I don't know where we are at with that, Danny, for the write-off that needs to be done in the aging. Did she start it or not? Because she's still not doing anything. Okay. So if she didn't start that, I don't understand. Okay. I've been.
Okay.
Ask to her to start doing that task at least a week and a half ago. She was off or on vacation or whatever, so we postponed it a little bit, but in my mind she should have started. OK, yes, so yes, go ahead, Satyaveer.
Yeah.
Sorry, I, sorry, I think that that is on me because I show her the process, but I understand that it was going forward, not going back to the previous transactions. Yes, no, sorry, that is on me.
Okay, bye.
Yes, yes, please. Okay, okay, in that case, no, no worries. So the other thing is that technically she should take over understanding better the business and if a client is disputing or ask question on number of hours, she should know and that may be, Sophia, I don't know if you provided, but she should know.
The.
Yeah.
Oh, this is a ticket for this person, this person, this person, because they have a list of client and responsibility and she should know that by now. Okay. So she cannot answer the client, but she can tag the person who cannot answer the client. So yeah. And those tasks she doesn't do yet. Am I right?
No, no, I have explained several times, but it's not clicking on her.
Kip.
Okay, so, okay, and that's a good thing you get involved. And maybe she has more difficulty with hearing than reading. Okay. Some people are like that. Okay, so maybe shadowing is not a cup of tea. Us, we don't have time for that. And that's usually what we do. And
Yeah.
Sophie, I'm pretty sure you use that tool. Do you record the Teams meeting better when you're doing shadowing?
As she did, actually, yes.
Okay, so technically she have all the transcript.
O.
Just so you know, maybe we don't have the SOP, but usually we record everything.
Yeah, which means that building an SOP should be cake, right? Because if she's got a transcript, she should be able to pull it.
Yep.
Exactly. Yeah, and she can always go back if she doesn't remember to do something. But if I, if I may for what I understand, and it seems that she have difficulty organizing herself. And for us, we give
S.
Team.
task. I don't think Sophia should start the day and saying, oh, from 9 to 10, you do this, from this to this, you do that. So because, again, I'm expecting a little bit more than that.
Right.
Yes, yes, because I need to follow up.
So, but I think she she cannot organize herself, and that's I think is the difficulty, but I don't think it's fall under us for a technical position like that.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, heard. And thank you, Manan, for sharing the extra context. I'm especially appreciative to hear that you guys from the shadow sessions do have transcript. I will, as the teams of value, like taking a look at this, we'll all keep that in mind.
Kasper.
Okay.
Perfect.
And if we hit any snags, having her try to pull those, because I'm happy to help her build whatever she needs to, assuming that we want to try to like drive forward and get her aligned with the, which would be the lowest, you know, friction.
Yeah.
Kip.
thing to do since she's been here for six months.
Yeah, yeah, but our goal would be that, but at one point I need my team to be efficient and when Sophia needs to always validate the work of somebody else, it means that Tammy is doing Sophia's work and I'm doing Tammy's work, so it doesn't work.
Right.
Hundred, absolutely, and that's what that's why I was saying before, Anand, right? That, from my perspective, our our objective here is to figure out, okay, how do we how do we get you the skill set that you actually need if if if Sally is not going to hit that mark? So, we'll take it internally.
Oops.
Yeah.
Yes.
for discussion, come with a plan and a recommendation, knowing you've got the transcripts, if I have to myself, sit with Sally and say, hey, here's the prompt I'm going to ask you to use to build this, or let's listen to it together and jot it down. Fine, I'll give the hour or the two hours to do it. It's not, that's not a concern for me.
Perfect.
Okay. Yeah, and yeah, and it's more Sophia and Reid that integrated Sally. So, but for us, we assumed that she knew she can come back to transcript. She can always find her transcript for the meeting. So I don't think we explained that to her. For us, it was a given that at least she needs to know how teams work.
I'm more concerned about you guys getting.
So we don't think we go that path. So maybe it's something that she doesn't even know, I don't know.
Right.
Yeah.
Yeah, and that's why I'm always, I often err on the side of caution both ways, right? So we'll, you know, nobody's going to go with any, we're not going to take bats or anything, but we will make sure that we're having the conversation and
Mm.
Mmh.
Okay.
Yeah.
And figuring out, figuring out, is this the right fit? Yep.
Big.
Okay, perfect. Okay, awesome. So that's great. Next week, I won't be on the call. It's A statutory day in, no, I will be on the call. It's Thursday. Yes, so we're fine. Okay. And we're okay also the week after. So just Tammy will take a day off. So we'll figure it out. If it's on Thursday, we'll let you know in advance.
we can reschedule or make sure that Teddy is part of it. Okay. And she's smiling because she doesn't want to go and I want her to rest.
Um...
She's making me go.
He.
Gaur.
So, are we fighting without knowing anybody knowing?
Yeah.
Okay.
He he he.
No.
I have the AR procedures that I was doing it. I can share with you. I'm just reviewing. There are a few things that we are not doing it. I can delete it for you.
As I said before, it's super simple. I mean...
Yeah, it's really a clerical task. It's not even for me a technique and I can't think technical task that she's doing. It's really the lowest data entry.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, it's helpful. Any and all detail that you have to share is valuable. I'm assuming there's already good stuff in the conversations that Arora had.
Okay.
Kip.
OK, but OK, perfect. So, Sophia, leave these the other tasks, don't delete them. OK, just say not doing, not doing, not doing. OK, so because if she's the person that she want, we want her to grow with us, she will have to learn those.
Okay, for sure.
You see what I mean? Okay, perfect.
For sure, for sure.
So, at least you know where we eventually we we want her to do, OK, with with the full the all the full tasks that she doesn't don't do right now. OK, anything else?
Look at me.
Yes.
Mhm.
Did we and did we talk a little bit about Krishna? No.
Yep.
No, well, no, yeah, no, first for Sally and then Krishna.
Okay. Okay, perfect. Okay. Because there's not a long time. So we feel that Krishna is really hurt, but what's going on. She seems to try not to avoid group meetings or team meeting or stuff like that. That's why I understand, Tammy. She was sick also.
Well, yeah, I'm okay with her. She's one on one meeting, I'm okay. Team meeting, she will attend, but she'll be silent. So.
Yeah.
No.
Kip.
So, bit.
So, and we understand it just that we wanted you guys to know, because it's sad, but you know what? Unfortunately, it happens to everybody sometimes that it doesn't work and you need to learn to cope with that. So I just wanted you to know.
Yeah.
I.
It's not an issue for us, we're managing, but I think that for her to grow, if you can help her, that would be a good thing.
Thank you. I'm appreciative of the feedback, despite knowing in 12 days, you know, that she'll turn down for you guys because of exactly what you just said, right? From our perspective, I don't know how much this has been clarified, but in general,
Mm.
Kip.
If A-team member is solid or has growth potential, we want to, you know, them not working with you all as a group doesn't mean that they're not going to work with IT by design. We have other opportunities from time to time. So understanding things like this is very helpful. We can offer her some guidance and feedback.
Thank you.
Mhm.
Okay.
Mmh.
in a constructive and hopefully helpful ways that she can grow from.
Yeah, and it's the objective of my comments. It's not saying that for us, it's okay. She's doing what she needs to do. She talked to Tammy. She's just that I feel that she's not comfortable and I don't know how you work with them. So I just want to make sure that, yeah, but it seems to be a tough time for her. So.
Yeah.
Thank you for the heads up. We'll take that into account.
Kip.
OK.
Perfect. Awesome. Bring me, I need to leave, so thank you. So, we'll, and my, my, Sophia will send you the notes, talk to her, but I would like that for next week, starting to talk about a plan and the objective and maybe some timeline. So,
Yeah.
Okay.
Kip.
Mhm.
Yeah.
just we understand the investment. There's a lot of stuff going on our way. We have projects to eventually change the system, other integration. So we, I need my senior people doing other stuff. So, okay, perfect. Awesome. Okay.
Makes perfect sense. Yeah, we'll come prepared for next week. Thank you.
Thank you. Have a good day. Thank you. Bye-bye. Bye.
Thank you.
Thanks. Thanks. Thanks, everybody. All right. Cheers.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, good day.
Bye.